All right, everybody. So this is the closest thing to Enigma. Now, I know actually he says
there is an Enigma, but
There is no Enigma, but this thing that I'm about to teach you right now is the closest thing to Enigma and
If you use this model correctly, I promise you you can actually make shit ton amount of money, okay?
Now I have a lot of videos on YouTube. I have a lot of models in
My courses in my first course we have models in this one we have models, but this is
what I trade I
Have never revealed this technique before so I'm just gonna close this here. So if you refer back to
the the one-minute range a strategy on NAS 100 I
Thought you how to trade ranges right on the one minute
But the problem that arises with this with that model is that
Let's suppose if price pushes in one direction
So to identify the range we first have to see a move to the upside or to the downside
So let's suppose that price went up, right? So that becomes our range high
So I want to teach you the best way to trade ranges, okay? And
If you understand this correctly, I promise you you will not need anything else and this is basically how I trade
Most of the time all right when this setup is present. I'm going to take it regardless of my bias regardless of the order flow
I do not care about that
So let's suppose that price pushes in one direction that is your range high
But the problem is that how do you actually identify the range low because what can price do is just keeps pulling back, right?
So is this the range low?
Or is this the range low right and you're gonna get faked out again and again most of the time
So how do you actually identify the range low because for a range to be valid?
We must have a range high and a range low, but
It's hard to identify the range low right, but I'm going to teach you the method and that is exactly the juice of this course, okay?
So all you have to do
Is look for a market structure shift. Now once you have a market structure shift, right?
This low over here caused a market structure shift. So
This low becomes range low. This is a valid range low
Not this low or not this low
But this low and this low caused what a market structure shift, right?
low low low low high low low and break in the structure and
This is where we have our range level now
We are simply waiting for price to either take take out the range low or range high
Ideally, I want to see the range low first taken out
Because because because in the in the in the on a high time frame
We could be going up right because we had an initial move to the upside. So
Ideally, I want to see this happen, but it is not necessary
It is just it's just going to increase your windowed by five percent at max
Okay, but you can see if price takes out high or low and then you can target the opposite liquidity
So range low range high right over here. So let's suppose that price comes down and it takes out
The range low, okay, so it works on all time frames
But I trade it on 15 minute and above
15 minute time frame is the best and above you can also trade all right a one hour is very good four hours very good
Daily time frame breaks very well if you want to identify daily bias as well
So range high range low range low was determined after we got a market structure shift now
Once the range low is taken we have to look for a market structure shift, right?
So let's suppose that we get a market structure shift now
Market structure shift when we get it we have to wait for price to come back above the range
This is very important market structure shift is not going to do anything by itself
We have to wait for price to close above the range the range low
We have to see price go up and close around here now
All you got to do is take your entry from the autoblock. So this right here consecutive down closed candles
That is your autoblock and from here you are going to take your entry
Okay, you're going to put your stock right below this low over here now for the risk management
This is a very important and if you skip the step the strategy will not work for you very simple
Okay, so we have to use our fit from the range high to range low
Now you have to copy these settings and you have to enable 0.79 level as well now
Your initial entry is going to be here
you are going to take a
Partial at 0.5 level and you're also going break even when price hits the 0.5 level
So when price goes up and hits the 0.5 level you're taking one partial alright
Then what can happen is price will pull back slightly and then it will push up now
sometimes
0.79 should be your main target because often what price will often do is it will go to the 0.79 level and then it will reverse
okay, if
Your your you know your narrative is bullish then you hold tail negative
Sorry than one level the range high okay, or what you can do is take one partial at 0.5
The other at 0.79 and then close your entire position at one or
You simply just take one partial at 0.5 and then you let the trade running until the range high is taken out
very simple very mechanical and
For the peers right peers. What does it work with really well?
So I'm going to give you guys some pairs and assets right but before we do that
I'm going to teach you the opposite example. So where we shot it right so let's assume that if I remove this this this this
Okay, perfect. We have the range low range high and let's suppose that price takes out
The range high right all we are doing afterwards is looking for a market structure shift, okay
Then we are looking to take our entry from the autoblock. So that is going to be the consecutive up closed candles
Right you are going to take your short position from this autoblock stop right above the high and
Again, we are going to use
From range low to range high right and we're gonna get the 0.79 level here 0.5 level here then you take your entry
one partial at 0.5 go break even then you can close your entire trade at 0.79 or
You hold till range low, okay, and and basically that's how the strategy works perfect, okay now
Let's suppose that
What makes this set up a low probability setup and I'm going to explain that right now
So let's suppose that price goes to 0.5 level
Before giving you an entry so you get a market structure shift
But you don't get a retest of the autoblock and price goes to the 0.5 level and below
then the setup becomes very low probability and if
Price goes to the 0.79 level without giving you an entry then the setup becomes entirely invalid
So we took out the range high we closed below the range which is very important. We have to close below the range
Okay, we cannot get a market structure somewhere around here
and you then you cannot take an entry from there you have to wait for price to close back into the range and
Ideally, I do not want to see price go way up like that and then come back
Then your stop loss gonna be massive and it just makes no sense right
so now that we know how to trade and identify the range high and range low I'm gonna give you guys some examples and
then we'll
And the video but let's suppose that you price pushes down in one direction, right?
So how do you basically identify range high now?
We have range low right price pushes down in one direction
That is your range low and then you have to look for a range high and you get it once you get a market structure shift
So over here we have a higher high high low higher high high low higher high and then we finally get a market structure shift
Right and this could be like of any low right it doesn't have to be significant low
So let's suppose if price creates a low somewhere around here if it breaks then that is a valid
Cause for this to become a range high as well
I'm gonna show you examples and then you will understand what I'm trying to say
But when you get a market structure shift that becomes your range
High because oftentimes what you will see whenever you get a market structure shift and then you take your entry
And then you lose a trade you ask yourself why did this not work out and then this is very simple prices just engineering a range
Okay, it's engineering range and that's all it's doing every single time
Well, of course not in the trending market, but when price starts to consolidate. That's what it's doing
So let's assume that price takes out the range low you get a market shift close above the range autoblock entry and boom
Just like that. So let me give you guys some examples now
Okay for the peers and assets and crypto that it works with so it works with all the crypto, you know
assets and pairs right
Every single one of them. I don't care whether it's low cap or high cap
It works with every single crypto coin
Okay, you can trade anything and the best time frame if you want to sculpt and you want to be an intraday trader
Is the 15-minute time frame you can trade the one hour a four hour daily as well and even weekly if you are a swing trader
but in this example you can see we have the BNB USDT and also
It works with NAS100 right it works with your USD and gold as well
I suggest you avoid trading any other pair with it. Just stick to your USD
NAS100 and
Crypto every single crypto coin. It's gonna work phenomenally. So
Price pushes up in one direction. That is your range. What?
Range high now, we have to identify the range low. So is this a range low?
I want to ask you a simple code. Is this a range low right here?
Is this a range low? No, why because it didn't break any structure. We didn't get a market structure ship, right?
So we have to wait and then you can see price pushes up and then it breaks this structure
This gives us a market structure shift. So
This right here becomes our range low
So we have range high range low and then afterwards what happens? We look for a market structure ship
Right there and our entry from the autoblocks
So if I turn on the executions here, you can see I took this trade myself
Entry was around somewhere here stops somewhere around here and at the range low I closed my position
So you can see how well this works. Let me give you guys another example
All right, so here is another example looking at sand USDT and I have the range high marked out here
price pushes up in one direction and
To identify the range low we have to look for a market structure shift. So we have a lower low lower high lower low
And then afterwards we have a market structure shift. Okay. This is not a range low
This is a range low. Why because this low caused a market structure shift to the upside?
So what happens we mark this out as our range low now?
We are simply looking for a price to take out the range lower range high and you can see price takes out range low
You get a market structure shift and that is our autoblock
But you can take your entry from a little discount because the autoblock is big and you need to have a good
Rich reward ratio. So if I turn on the executions here
You can see I entered somewhere around here my stop was somewhere around here because I believed price will not go here
This was a tight range. So in this scenario, I put my stop here, but I recommend you always put it here
I'm okay with losing trades guys
But if you are someone who is not okay with losing trades, then please do put your stop here long here TP here
I'm out and I'm just going about with my day. Let me give you guys another example
All right, so this is an example with forex and the high probability ranges on forex and
NAS 100 are gonna form pre Asia session. So
The you know the no session price, right? So in this from this area to this area
Price will form a high probability range or within the Asian range
So we have a push to the downside, right? So we have range low price pushes back up
We need to identify range high and we do so by identifying a market structure shift
So we have a higher high high low high high low and then a higher high then we get a market structure shift right here
So this becomes our range high right very simple then you can see price goes up
Takes out the range high we look for a market structure shift
And then we have this auto block price taps into this auto block
Oops my bad right there, and you can see the push to the downside and then price goes back down again
Goes up again. I don't care what it does, but I am out of the market and then this setup is complete
Let's move on to another example
So here is another example with your USD we push down we create a range low over here
We can go up and look closely. We have a hard high
hard low
Higher high high low and then a higher high and then afterwards we have a market structure shift
So this becomes our range high so we have range low and then we have a range high and then look what happened afterwards
We take out the range low and then we push back up
Price gives us a market structure shift and if you look closely this low was protected price never came below it
So that was your entry you put up stop you could have put your stop here, right?
And you can see how well it was but it was not the cleanest setup
But you can see that let's suppose that you took your entry from the auto block stop right below here
You target this level that would have given you 2.81 rr
So you can see the power of this strategy guys like I said before
This is the closest thing that comes to a nigma. There's no other stuff a thing called a nigma guys trust me on this
I've been trading for like
so many years now and
This though this way of trading is one of the best ways and I personally use this every single day
Mostly with crypto, but if there's a set of present on forex or indices I traded right away. Let's move on to next example
All right guys, this is an example with nasa 100 price pushes down pre issue session
You mark out the issue low
Then we wait for a range high formation. So high high high low
high high
High low and then a higher high and then you can see we'll wick through this level
So this becomes a range high
Because this high caused a market structure shift to the downside
Then we take out the range high and then we look for a market structure shift
So high high high low higher high
Market structure shift, but notice what happens here price didn't close below the range. So we wait for it that happens right there
And then look at this
The autoblock right here. This is the highest candle right up close candle
Tap into it
And price goes right to the range low and then from there onwards. I don't care what price does our setup is complete
Let me give you guys one more example
All right guys, this is the last example i'm looking at
Us dt and you can see we have a push to the upside. So that is our range high
And then we are looking for a market structure shift. So we have a lower low
You can see president take out the low. So that is not a valid market structure shift
We need to see lower low lower high lower low and then a market structure shift. Okay
So price goes down once again, right and then we have this market structure shift right here. We also broke the structure. So
So this level becomes our range
Low so we have a range high range low
Then price sweeps this high high high low higher high
Then a shift in the market structure. We have a fair value gap
And you can take your entry from the 50% of the autoblock as well
Or on the retest of the range high
You can see this would have been somewhere your entry would have been somewhere around here stops right above the high
And you can see how well this played out
Price takes out liquidity and then it pushes somewhere else. I don't care, but our play is done here
So that was it guys. Thank you for watching. I'll see you guys in a couple of weeks